today exciting we're going to be doing
YouTube channel breakdown what I found
is by looking at one person's Channel
you often get ideas on what you can do
for your own as well so hopefully the
examples we go through will be helpful
for you as well so I'm going to start by
pulling up lady Lexi's Channel and get
some feedback so you can get some get
your messages out to the world make it
an impact having a difference and also
hopefully making you some more money as
well so when I first look at a channel
and again this is something hopefully
all of we all of us can learn from first
thing we look at is our banner and our
Avatar here right so I can see her face
here cool this is probably a little too
much text and Lady this is something
that we've been talking a lot about when
I come and land on this channel what are
you all about and so new show new show
we don't have to make the test
promotional imagine somebody who doesn't
know who you are so we're not talking to
people who already know us we're talking
to brand new people so what do they need
to know about us I'm less concerned
about the time nobody really consumes
YouTube videos by time nobody's like oh
my gosh Evan you were five minutes late
on your video what happened or you
forgot the post yesterday what happened
we're not so important in people's lives
right where most people subscribe to a
couple hundred channels so they're not
really paying attention so the schedule
doesn't really matter
um so I wouldn't worry about most of
this a new show a new show would take
out weekly on Wednesday is a time
schedule I would take out and it's more
like what what are you all about what's
the value I'm going to get from the
channel what am I going to learn how am
I going to improve myself what what am I
going to leave watching your videos
feeling and so that's the messaging that
we want to have on here I would change
the Avatar to be you
unless this becomes your character for
all the videos but it's not anywhere in
in your videos so I would make this you
and for most of you I got asked
yesterday in a presentation is it is it
better to do your company logo as your
brand or your face and almost always the
answer is face because people connect
with people a lot more and they'll
connect with a logo
The Only Exception is if if you are a
bigger company or you have multiple
people on the team who are going to be
on the videos then there might be a case
for that but you guys are all individual
Brands like we're trying to build your
brand up not not for your ego and people
to you know say how amazing you are but
to serve and to help and you should be
instantly recognizable so this should be
your face lady Lexi
um and then even the title so if I look
at this combination what do we think
like if and you know some good comments
if you guys want to leave some comments
here if you were forget about the videos
if you just saw this Banner
with the background you know we got this
water this beach and then you saw the
title lady Lexi's life on the road what
do you what kind of channel do you think
this would be
I thought it was a travel Vlog says
Anita
in the chat if you were just to happen
on this
traveling says Mary travel says Andre
so we're getting a lot of travel
thoughts and uh this is probably what I
would think too to be honest right it's
like oh lady likes his life on the road
she's gonna be traveling she's going to
be going places look at her on the beach
um which is not really what the channel
is all about or maybe maybe it used to
be I don't know
um but
what is the story that you've been
through I mean on the on the gaming
stream when you've been joining in
um Brian says look there's too much
going on there Lydia says meditation Joy
says traveling shocks as meditation or
yoga a lot of it has been your healing
Journey it's been about speaking up it's
been about finding the right doctor to
support you on your journey right so
what's the imagery that supports that
uh the meditation is probably the
closest thing
to the journey is not so much about
travel and beaches Etc so I would
rethink that style behind you so that
people when they first land because
again we're not talking to our friends
and people who know us it's brand new
people who've never heard us before we
don't want them to think probably that
we are a travel vlog
now looking at the thumbnails I know
you've been doing a lot of work getting
the text uh shorter so I think some of
the older videos had a lot of text and
if we look down so if we look at you
know some of these for example right
you can't read that and I'm on my
computer now go to my phone and it's
going to be super tiny it's just
impossible to read impossible to see who
these people are and so good job on
doing the work to get it to something
like this where it is so much easier to
read than this The Next Step would be to
make the font easier to read so
this font any fancy font is hard to read
especially small and you gotta imagine
people are scrolling through really
quickly through your videos just like
they're imagine they're walking through
an uh a grocery store aisle and they're
picking what cereal box that they're
going to pick the one that stands out
the most is the one they're gonna pick
so your videos might be showing up on
people's feeds but they're scrolling so
it has to stop them from scrolling and
make it instantly something that they
want to be able to click on and so
making the text legible and a good size
is important
uh so the sizing is a lot better now but
the font Choice makes it hard and the
color scheme makes it hard so all of
these stylized fonts should be used very
sparingly even all of this is is hard to
read
the stylized fonts are really hard to
read so what you want to do is use thick
chunky easy to read fonts that when
they're really small really stand out so
if you're looking at
uh yeah and the good news about YouTube
is you can go back and redo all these
things now you can go back and you can
update all of these videos as well you
can change the thumbnail Style on them
to make it stand out a little bit more
so there is a lot going on here I would
stick to a color scheme usually we'd
look at uh like a neutral colors look
like white black if you look at mines
like white black and gold
right you can potentially throw in a
second accent color if you want but
just that color scheme then makes it
easy to say hey that's an Evan
Carmichael video and that becomes the
goal it's like I want people to say that
is a lady Lexi video
uh next in terms of the pictures
generally bigger faces work so faces
work for sure
when it's just text it doesn't work as
well and when it's just a picture it
doesn't work as well so faces with text
works the best uh and again I need to be
able to see you from the phone so a lot
of these pictures are too small this one
is probably your best one where I can
clearly see you right I can see you
imagine I'm scrolling super quick
through the videos right if I'm
scrolling I don't know I mean even
looking at this on a computer I don't
know that this is you these five
pictures of Lady Lexi so I would zoom in
and make it something like this as much
as possible if you're having two people
then you can have them side by side you
can have them one on each side obviously
this is Terry way Thompson fellow
movement makers we love you Terry
um all of this should be zoomed in more
so you could be you on the side
Terry on one side text in the middle or
both of you on one side and text on the
side
um the faces get a little bit smaller
when you're using two people on the
thumbnail but it could still be bigger
than what we've been using here so a lot
of this is just getting people to uh to
click
if I can't read the text and I can't see
the face I'm not likely to click and if
I am confused by what the channel is all
about right if I think it's a travel
Vlog then I'm probably not going to
watch the video as well next thing for
any video is the starting has to be
awesome you want you want to hook people
right away so step one is
just in terms of The Branding does this
person look like somebody who I want to
learn from
right so do they look like me it doesn't
have to be back to Titan twin content
you don't have to look like you're Oprah
Winfrey but does it look like you know
what I've been through
and can you solve my problem
right so you know Alex in here doing his
salsa dancing this should be a salsa
dance at the top right it shouldn't just
be Alex's face it should be people's
salsa dancing if Zane's doing one around
confidence it should feel like I'm gonna
get more confidence just by looking at
the banner and the Avatar right so
that's step one like branding are you
the person that I think will help me
solve my problem step two is then with
your click-through rate having
thumbnails and titles that will get
people to want to click on the video and
then step three is keeping people in the
video so if you look at a video the
starting point has to be really powerful
so ladies fairly consistent right 10
hours ago and 19 hours ago one day ago
seven days ago seven days ago seven days
ago nine days ago okay so the next for
scheduling for anybody here I would
space these out more instead of doing
three videos on one day take a week off
and then do three videos again on on
another day space these out so that
you're not squishing them all together
this would be better to have you know
six videos over seven days instead of
three videos in one day and then three
videos on another day and then have a
big break in between
the length is good 30 minutes 16 minutes
an hour 42 minutes 29 minutes 42 minutes
the length is good and then if we play
we can see how it starts
done with it I'm not going to do this
well that's when enough is enough it's
when you realize that your or
experiencing
mental or physical problems that
you get that pit in your stomach that
you know something needs to be done
and you are willing to go this is not
bad this is not bad the thing that would
change I mean we could get we could be
more
emotional it's like the first sentence
has to matter the fir you have to feel
it you're not just making a video you're
talking to somebody
but this is a lot better than than the
live streams where you're just kind of
welcoming people and having a good time
so this is a lot better and I would also
not lead with this never lead with a
static image go right to you
go or people talking right never lead
with just audio in a static image
because you want people to see your face
immediately you'll just lose people when
it's a static image
um but that one that part's getting a
lot better and then just more emotion
like imagine that this matters imagine
that your message is going to change
somebody's life today and try to
approach you with that
um not intensity but just intentionality
you know that somebody is gonna
somebody's in a really tough spot right
now they're going to watch your video
and they're going to only listen to the
first three sentences and the words that
you say matter but even more important
is the
emotion that you have in it
um so so this is great this is a great
start and then looks like you're moving
around and now you're outside and now
you have guests on board
um once you start getting data you can
pay attention to uh where the audience
retention is falling off like where are
you losing people you can look at your
data and see but but this is a fantastic
start
yeah I like it so the biggest thing for
you then is update update the banner
update the Avatar continue working on
the thumbnails to make the text super
easy to read zoom in on the faces and
the start of your videos making them
more emotional and uh to the point
today we're going to talk about how to
find where my 1000 true fans are hiding
it's a good topic
um when I saw it pop up I was pumped
yesterday to uh start diving into some
thoughts I love the polling system we
created I really love it I love that you
guys are giving feedback on what you
want to talk about and we're pulling
some of the things from the book but
then also what I really love about this
group is I can share my my current best
practices like what am I doing exactly
right now so a lot of the examples I'm
going to share are just what I was doing
yesterday you know when you write a book
you want it to last right so you can't
always share exactly what you're doing
right now because it's going to change
in six months it's going to change in a
year it's going to change in five years
right I want people in 10 years to still
read this book and find it valuable but
the the value of this group is you get
you get the access to exactly right now
what I'm working on so it's always so
much fun putting these together for you
so let's dive in so how to find where my
1000 true fans are hiding
as always giving a shout out to who came
up with this topic Mr Ben McNeil I don't
know if Ben's in the house I was in the
house yet I haven't seen you Ben if
you're in the house say hi walk aboard
thank you for the awesome topic so how
to find where my 1 000 true fans are
hiding so number one they're not hiding
you are when I first saw this topic I
was excited but also a little a little
tiny bit put off just in the warning
because I want you guys to always take
100 accountability Right This is How I
Live it's my fault it's my
responsibility to get out there and make
the progress that I want and the
beginning is great right how to how to
seeking answers you're looking you're
searching you're trying to find it but
that last part of hiding
they're not hiding right that's putting
that's putting you know the blame and
responsibility on them they're not
hiding for for too many of us it's it's
you right like you're hiding you're not
posting enough content you're not
sharing your story enough you're not
putting yourself out there you're not
creating enough
right and I know I know it's hard and
we'll talk about some of the ideas here
later on in this in this presentation
but
um
if you're not where you want to be yet
it's it's a direct result of your effort
your abilities your skill set your
putting in the work right but I just
wanted to to
highlight in the language and I know
this wasn't Ben's intent I know Ben in
post in it was not saying it's their
fault but just just being careful about
the word choice that we're using and the
stories that we're telling ourselves
because
they're not hiding the problem is not
that your fans are hiding the problem is
that you're hiding and we need to
unleash that and that's that part in the
book that's part of this program it's
part of this presentation
um and so I'm super excited to
help unleash that so I know sharing is
scary
talk about it in the book
um whenever I say BTS has built the
serve page 108 if you want more
references you can go in and check it
out I have this picture of me and Alex
up because we discovered uh last week or
two weeks ago that Alex has a learning
disability
uh
one ADHD which is super common but also
something called the executive
functioning
anyway and it's been it's been hurting
he's you know had it his whole life just
kind of figured it out now uh he learns
slower than most people things that I
don't have to repeat to others I have to
go over multiple times with him before
he finally gets it and now we're trying
to devise kind of strategies and
techniques and how we can learn more
effectively but what I told him
yesterday and this is why I love this
group is I can share what's happening
right now yesterday was Alex you have to
share that story you have to share that
you have a learning disability you have
to share how that makes you feel you
have to share the impact that is having
on you trying to be an entrepreneur
trying to build the business trying to
live your life how does it hit you
because other people will connect to
that right and and he he doesn't know
how to process it yet he's worried about
you know judgment and how people see it
uh he you know wants to talk to his mom
first and all this stuff but in sharing
is the thing that will make people
connect to you
and so he's already shared his stories
about
hyperhidrosis and and being the
excessive sweating and um not being able
to talk to girls and all this stuff and
a lot of it is in is in the book but
this just happened you know last week
and yesterday was my conversation with
him about you have to share this with
your audience and that's actually part
of the healing
that is actually part of the healing
because as long as you're worried about
it as long as you're afraid of the
judgment and what people might say about
it you keep it hidden you keep yourself
plain small and then you don't create
any amazing content and that secret owns
you and so I told them great go talk to
your mom awesome but then you have to go
post
he's like we'll try to post it as a
story should I post it as Instagram live
like it doesn't matter just get it out
there
just get it out there so that somebody
watches it and gives you some kind of
comment I mean the comments are all
going to be positive right nobody's
going to come on and say Alex I never
knew you were a dummy right at least I
hope not
but in sharing it and getting the secret
out there it's it's incredibly
empowering and other people will then be
inspired as well to talk to Alex about
their learning disability and be able to
share in their life the things that are
happening so this is part of the hiding
this is part of the hiding that we all
go through is the story that you're
afraid to share is the thing that you
have to share to help people connect to
you it makes sense logically it's just
difficult
it's difficult to share the thing that
you don't want other people to know
it's still hard like Alex has gone
through this Alex has been around me for
five years so he knows this but it's
still hard right so that's fine it's
meant to be hard
but getting it out there becomes the
healing process
in in Bill to serve page 63 we talk
about being the tree and so my my
concept of the tree is
um the tree is designed to breathe in
uh carbon dioxide right which is too
much for a human is poison it eats it it
grows cement and then it spits out
oxygen
for the world and I see that as our job
as thought leaders as movement makers is
your job is partly to eat the negativity
to eat the criticism to eat the judgment
to grow from it and then spit out oxygen
positivity for the world for the people
who currently are who you used to be
and so when I say they're not hiding you
are what I want to see is more
consistency more vulnerability more
personal storytelling more effort and
care right more more more and more and
it may not you may not have great
results yet you may not be proud of the
finished product yet because you're
still learning still getting better
still trying but all of these things the
more you the more you can apply them the
more you can become that tree the more
you're sharing your story
you're going to find that the people
your thousand true fans suddenly come
out of air quotes hiding
right they come out of hiding because
you've given them permission to
because for them to come out of hiding
you need to come out of hiding first
does that make sense
uh Joshua saying my favorite
illustration was the tree
yeah I don't know where that came from
um
it was off I was doing some podcast and
uh it was with uh somebody who was into
like psychedelics and and crazy stuff
um and I and I told him that he's a tree
and then I said you know what that's a
great that's a great analogy anyway okay
so I don't know if Ben is here Ben
saying hi if you're here I might have
missed it if you are but um so Ben and
this is not meant to be a knock at Ben
right Ben I went to his Facebook account
and he posted once three days ago and
then one six days ago and and maybe he's
posting somewhere else I couldn't find
his Instagram or anything else but uh
this is where now we need to step up
right this is part of the hiding if
we're posting two times in six days if
you want to be a thought leader and and
get your message out there it has to be
more frequently right back to here more
consistency more vulnerability more
personal storytelling more effort and
care so if I'm running Ben's page here I
want to I want to see those things I
want to see the consistency right so six
times in six days right I want to see
the storytelling right here it's just
telling me about a new podcast and what
does it say new podcast with Naomi
awesome uh use a discounted code to get
prices awesome I mean
there's no vulnerability there there's
no storytelling I'm sure the podcast
itself is great but tell me in the
content that you're posting right and so
more care more effort more storytelling
more more vulnerability more consistency
that's how you pull them out of hiding
by you leaning by example
that making sense
and and I love Ben this isn't this again
is not meant to be a knock against Ben
or or any of you guys that just pulled
his profile as an example I bet if I
went into a lot of your profiles would
be something similar and and I want you
to take the accountability and start
creating the content that you need to to
track the people to build your movement
of the impact you want to have
today what I'm going to talk about
is how to choose and create an online
product or service that can be scaled
and sold digitally super important uh
you are thought leader you're an expert
you have wisdom to share and being able
to monetize your ideas your wisdom is
important because if you're not making
money
then you have a side hobby not a real
business is going to have a big impact
so one of the things that I cover in
build to serve is what I call the recipe
for success and you see BTS are on the
screen because that means built to serve
so there's there's
a couple questions that I asked that if
you can figure this out it's then a
recipe that you can teach other people
so you think about how did you save
yourself so you're built to serve you
want to help other people who are
currently going through the same thing
that you went through right so you know
think about who you were five or ten
years ago that person what they're
struggling with right you're going back
and talking to yourself that's going to
be your ultimate purpose and now we need
to figure out a way to monetize that so
you can do that and have a bigger reach
so how did you save yourself
how did you get out of the hole that you
were in
and it may not have been a super clear
path right maybe you tried a whole bunch
of different things
and some of them didn't work most of
them probably didn't work and and for a
lot of us whatever hole you were in I
remember me being an entrepreneur I love
helping entrepreneurs because I
struggled so much as an entrepreneur I
struggled and tried so many different
things I felt like I had all these
different ideas and I tried them all and
nothing worked and I failed and I failed
and I failed and I failed until I found
the thing that actually worked which was
modeling success looking at Bill Gates
and how he started Microsoft I copied
that that idea of Partnerships Microsoft
built their business through
Partnerships
their big deal came with IBM where every
IBM computer shipped had Microsoft
software on it and Microsoft is already
a seven million dollar company when that
happened
so how did they get the seven million
same thing through Partnerships I
started applying Partnerships to my
business and suddenly had my first check
for thirteen and a half thousand dollars
which was mind-blowing to me which I'm
making 300 bucks a month so 13 and a
half K was huge and then they gave me a
recipe they could do again and again and
again and again so I I tried so many
things I felt like I tried everything I
tried everything in my head right and
nothing was working until finally the
partnership strategy came through by
modeling Bill Gates and and that helped
explode my business forward what have I
done since
it's just more modeling success right I
mean that was back when I was 19. so
it's been 20 years of just modeling
success and trying to help now other
entrepreneurs model success right if you
look at my channel and the content it's
me sharing my ideas and modeling what
other people are doing and so I tried a
whole bunch of stuff most of it didn't
work and then finally here's this one
thing that worked I went hardcore at it
and that's what I've been teaching for
the past 20 years so same thing for you
you went through a really tough time you
went through massive challenges you
never want to go back to that really
painful moment and you know there's so
many people who currently are in that
most painful moment you've tried so many
things right you used to try so many
things most of the things didn't work
out but finally you hit on one two or
three things that actually worked that
started working for you that is then
when you can teach other people
to help them shortcut the path right
you're a mentor you're a teacher you're
a guide now right you've you may not
have totally come out on the other side
but you're ahead of where you used to be
and so that's your opportunity to say
I've been through what you're going
through I've tried all those things that
you're trying and didn't work but here
is the one that actually opened up the
gates for me this is the one thing that
when you figure this out can explode
your whole growth forward
so for me it was my own success for you
what was it and so the question of how
did you save yourself and sometimes it's
difficult because we don't want to think
back to the negative and what you know
where we're in our really low points but
you have to not the point to live there
but
the point of being able to go back and
save yourself and other people like you
so how did you save yourself so step one
recipe for Success ask yourself these
three questions one when you decide that
something had to change so if I look at
my story I struggled as an entrepreneur
and and nothing was working and I'm
making 300 bucks a month and I was too
embarrassed to tell my friends that I
wasn't working out
and I just kept trying trying trying it
was when I told my business partner that
I quit
one night on a on a you know
Thanksgiving or some kind of family
holiday and I I told my partner I quit I
can't do this anymore I need to I need
to feel like a worthwhile human being
the next day I woke up and said I can't
quit I just have to find a different way
to stand because I'm going to regret it
if I quit right now because I haven't
given everything I've got and that
opened me up to thinking I can't be the
first person to have gone through this
like somebody else has done it and
that's what led me to Bill Gates because
he's built the software company he's the
only guy I could think of who built a
software company I was in software uh
and so that's when it had to change
that's when I decided something had to
change that the way that I'm going can't
continue to go as it is right now
something has to change so for you and
your life when did you decide that it
had to change you were probably in that
painful situation for months or years or
for for some people a decade you you've
struggled for so long and then boom this
marking point that said now this has to
change right connecting to that and
writing that down like when was the
moment that you decided that it had to
change for you because when you can
identify that moment for you you can
then give it and gift it to other people
to help them have their moment as well
because until they decide that it has to
change nothing's going to happen you can
give them the best answers the best
strategies what you know works but
they're not going to do it because they
haven't decided to change
so it starts with you sharing your story
of when you decided that it had to
change for you and and maybe you know it
maybe you have to dig deep and find it a
lot of this worked for me I had to dig
back and find it because I'm naturally
one I don't think backwards and I don't
I don't especially negative thoughts
going backwards I live in the present
and the future so it took me some work
to find it maybe you know absolutely
where it is right for you right now but
um do the work to figure out when did
you decide that this had to be a must
that you wanted to change so the next
part of that is
what was the first thing that you did to
start the change
what was the first thing that you did
when you decided that you had to change
what was the next step that you took
because this is something we're now
going to teach to other people you're
going to help them decide that they have
to change and then you have to give them
the first easy step for them to start
making progress so for me I was alone I
did it by myself chances are for you you
are alone you did it by yourself you're
going to help it be easier for other
people because now they've got you
they've got a guide they've got a mentor
they've got a sage they've got somebody
to lead them down the path
so for me it was thinking
who has done this before I can't be the
first person to do it I looked at Bill
Gates and I started researching his
story what was the very first thing that
you did
after you decided
because once somebody decides we have to
get the momentum this is now going to be
your job how do you help somebody one
decide and then two get momentum it may
not be anywhere close to them hitting
the final goal right just thinking about
Bill Gates doesn't mean I'm going to
build a successful software company
but the process of getting started of
building momentum is the biggest thing
that most people are just missing they
haven't decided and then they have no
momentum so what's the very first thing
that they need to do to give them
momentum and what's amazing about you
guys is you
are guiding them and giving them hope
where chances are for you there was
nobody helping you out
so with your hope with your advice with
you saying I've been through this you
can make it through this as well your
belief in them gives them belief in
themselves you got through there's a lot
of people who never make it through
whatever you struggled with there's a
lot of people who never actually get on
the other side we've decided to change
we figured what our first thing was to
make the change and then how did you
sustain the momentum so
it's amazing that you did that first
step
what did you then do every day to
sustain that momentum because so many
people have these Great Moments and then
they relapse right you've got these
Great Moments and then you stop saying
consistent you fall apart it goes away
so
what did you do did you did you put it
in your calendar did you get an
accountability partner did you read a
book every day like what was the thing
that helped you sustain the energy and
momentum so that it wasn't just this
one-off moment of boldness one one up
moment of greatness and then you fell
back down right and so for me I
dedicated myself every day to learning
from some successful entrepreneur
I picked up a book called radicals and
Visionaries that is out of print it's
not honestly that great a book but
it is basically what my YouTube channel
became where it showed a famous
entrepreneur and their story in three to
four pages and every day I would wake up
and just read a story from that book
three to four pages right super easy one
it got me motivated and two it gave me
ideas of what I could do to continue to
help build my business and so that's
what I would do every morning is try to
be around some other successful
entrepreneur YouTube wasn't around 20
years ago so I didn't I didn't have that
to to be able to help me otherwise it
would be all in on watching a video
every single morning
but for you what was the thing how did
you sustain the momentum every day to
now get you out of the hall and doesn't
mean you were perfect maybe you had some
low moments on your climb up but you're
climbing You're Building you're moving
so this process that you went through
is your recipe for success and it's
teachable
this is the whole point of this this is
teachable your path out may have taken
you 10 years to get to where you are but
you can condense it down and teach it to
other people
that's how you build your movement
that's how you start getting paid that's
how you start making an impact on the
people that you want to make an impact
right so we're condensing your 10-year
journey into
a week a month six months however long
it's actually going to take people to do
but massively condense down from X
number of years for you to get here
because you failed and you struggled and
you had no coach or Mentor you're going
to give them the path and you're going
to coach and Mentor them so they can get
there much faster and maybe save their
life for some of you I know your story I
know where you came from you're actually
dealing with life or death situations
for me it was just entrepreneurship I
felt low as a human I was never suicidal
you know depressed I was never anywhere
close to be on the edge of you know
ending my life or anything
life-threatening but for some of you
guys like that's real
um and I've heard your stories I don't
know all your stories here in the group
but I've heard some of your stories and
what you could do could actually save
people's lives
um and so I'm really pumped for for you
to get this out there
influence and persuasion so number one
is coaching and wearing their skin it's
super valuable I like to say that I wear
people's skin I think if you're a great
coach you wear people's skin where
you're telling them what they should do
versus what you would do this is a this
is a big separation that a lot of people
don't get yes you have been through it
and yes you have your recipe for Success
that can help them but the exact step
they may need next may not be the one
that you exactly did and so the more you
can think what does this person in front
of me right now need versus what you
would do in their situation makes you a
better coach
and I'll often give advice that I would
never do myself
um it also means that I uh I'll often
talk like people so I remember I coached
and mentored Lily to help her build a
coaching practice and she had this one
session we had where she was frustrated
and upset and and was swearing a lot and
so I started swearing back to her
and she said I've never heard you swear
before like I'm not I'm you
right I think that I think the best
coach
for you to be the best coach is for you
to be and reflect back the best version
of the person that you're talking to
so when I was swearing back at Lily it
wasn't me talking it was the better Lily
I had a twitch session last night
um where uh a guy came on and he said
the trust your gut and like yes trust
your gut I am your gut I told him I am
your gut I was reflecting back what he
needed to hear the best version of him
again not necessarily what I would do
but what he needs to do
uh so you're wearing their skin it's not
just trying to be like them it's being
them you become the best version of them
so as you get more practice uh you'll
discover pattern recognition you'll see
the same things happening over and over
and over and over again and that'll help
lead you to faster steps so you know you
see where they are right now you know
they can get here but you don't quite
know the steps to take them through the
more you do it the more you'll say oh
this person's like that person who I
helped last week and and yesterday and
last month and you can go faster Through
the Motions always listening to your own
gut and then using the 85 rule this is
from build to serve uh page 240 where
you are when you're 85 sure you're 100
sure
you're asked questions until you get to
85 then once you get to 85 you go into
coaching mode so the first part about
influence and persuasion is being the
best version of them because they don't
want to listen to you but they want to
listen to them and so
a lot of people if they don't like what
I'm saying it's because they don't like
themselves I'm just reflecting
themselves back
uh and a lot of times if you jump into a
coaching session this is why it's
sometimes hard for the Instagram stuff
that I put up of coaching people a lot
of times it can come off as really harsh
if you watch some of my sessions with
people you can see how harsh sometimes I
am I am on them
um and it's meant not for the audience
this is where I get into a fight with my
agent sometimes because he's like design
a show for the audience it's not meant
for the audience it's meant for that
person I want that person to get a
result
and we're we're jumping steps even if
the audience can't understand it
and so sometimes I come off as super
soft and sometimes super hard and
sometimes pushy and sometimes will swear
and sometimes whatever because what that
person needs to get the results so try
to get out of your own way try to get
out of what you would do and step into
their shoes and say what should they do
versus what I would do okay so this is
the 85 rule explained it's in the book
basically when you're 85 sure then you
then you are a hundred
you act like you're 100 but you become a
hundred because when you have confidence
in something that confidence leads for
the other person to have confidence
if you're 85 sure
and listen there's always going to be
some doubt because you don't actually
know this person you're coaching and
helping right there's always going to be
some level of Doubt but if you have any
doubt when you're giving them advice
they're afraid of the advice in the
first place they're afraid to make the
change and so they don't want to make
the change and they're going to hang on
to the doubt
even though you're 85 sure or 90 sure if
you allow for a hedge if you allow for a
little bit of doubt
they're going to hang on to that doubt
and then not take action
and that was a mistake I made earlier on
going through this process of coaching
and helping people is that I would give
options I would hedge because I would
tell myself I don't really know this
person and so there could always be some
exception
but to assume that the person in front
of you is the exception when you're 85
sure is actually cheating them the
opportunity to grow
and so when you're 85 sure you become
100 sure and your confidence in them
allows them to have confidence in
themselves
your confidence and their ability
because you're absolutely certain that
they can do this thing this is the path
you can't accomplish this you can make
that song or write that book or break up
with that person or whatever the next
step is that they need to do you're 100
absolute confidence in their ability to
do this thing
is stronger
then their lack of confidence in the
thing right whoever's more confident
wins and so if you are more confident in
them than they are not confident in
themselves you win and they become more
confident in themselves that's why you
have to get 100 so how do you do this
you go question question question
question question question
you just keep asking questions you get
to 85 sure and then you coach and if you
watch my videos
when I'm helping somebody
you'll see that
they take this this similar Arc where
it's non-stop just
with no judgment asking them questions
you're making them feel safe you're
giving them an opportunity to share but
you're not putting them on the defensive
this is where a lot of new coaches mess
up
you're asking questions with an answer
already in mind and you're judging them
which puts them on the defensive a lot
of times when you're asking the
questions
it can be seen as judgmental it can put
them on the defensive you're you're
raising their walls which then becomes
really hard to push them forward
and so it's super important that all
you're doing in the questions is seeking
to understand I'm just trying to
understand all you're doing is asking
questions
understanding them until in your own
head you're coming up with this is what
the person needs to do
you get the 85 certainty and then it's
like a switch if you watch my videos of
coaching it's a switch
it shuts from just asking questions say
this is what you need to do I have
peeked into your soul
I'm wearing your skin
I'm 85 sure that means I'm a hundred
this is what you need to do
and now we're into coaching mode and
it's through the
the question asking in a non-judgmental
tone that you get the information that
you need
now sometimes you may not get to
an answer sometimes you may not know
what to do for them you may not know how
to help and this is where new coaches
really struggle because you're always
you're in Fix-It mode right you want to
help people always you want to help help
and and you tie yourself forth to
helping and if you don't help them get a
result then you feel worse about
yourself
understand that listen alone is value
you might be the only person who's ever
actually listened to this person
whatever they're struggling to deal with
you might be the only one who is there
for them who's who they can have a
conversation with like maybe the things
they're telling you they haven't told
their partner they haven't told their
parents they haven't told their friends
they haven't told their kids they
haven't told anybody that alone is value
even if you don't get to a solution of
what they should do next that alone is
value I mean think about Alex from
Toronto Dan salsa he's he's going
through this process with me uh even
this morning was messaging me helping
coach somebody else on our team at TDS
and
some of the mistakes that he's made in
his in his passion to want to go off and
help people is rush into a judgment is
asking questions that again put people
on the defensive and then they push him
away and don't want to talk to him
they they say oh here comes another
session because if you're pushing people
on the wrong thing you lose credibility
you lose respect you lose your ability
to influence and persuade so you have to
make sure that the thing that you're
pushing on is the thing that they need
exact help with and if you can't get
there it's okay listen alone is value
and through the pattern recognition and
repeat you'll get better at it so this
is what I told Alex to do to get better
Omegle is a place for people to chat
with strangers so I told Alex you have
to go on and chat with strangers
he's trying to spread belong he's trying
to help people uh and push them like
many of you to be the best version of
themselves he does it through his own
way and so go on go on Omegle
uh choose the video option and start
helping people listen to them and start
helping them so you get you get more of
a rapid turnaround on being able to get
the practice in because you may not be
doing chances are you're not doing
enough coaching right now you're not
doing enough helping right now you're
not doing enough of these things if
you're doing it once every two weeks
you're just not going to get good enough
right like do anything once every two
weeks you don't you don't develop the
the skill set fast enough right Michael
Jordan wasn't
shooting basketball once every two weeks
if you want to be the Michael Jordan of
this you need to practice practice so I
told them to go on Amigo and he's been
posting some of his videos onto YouTube
where you just chat with strangers and
people rotate through and you get it's
based off of interest and uh you get
some people come on and you just have a
conversation
and so you get to rapidly like you could
today go through 10 different people and
just practice practice practice your
listening practice your understanding
practice your questioning practice your
ability to get to 85 percent uh practice
you're then coaching to help them get a
result that they want
we are talking today about how to make
content that touches people's hearts we
talk about emotional commitment the
thing I struggled the most with and
we're gonna go and look at some of my
old videos and be embarrassed by how bad
it was at the start so just like your
success can be other people's
inspiration how much you sucked and kept
going can also be other people's
inspiration that's the goal for today's
session so emotional commitment I've
never even heard of this term before
this is one of the most important
changes that I made as a content creator
that started to make an impact and it
came from my agent Steve now this is a
picture of me and Steve when we went up
in New York and my first videos weren't
that great and you can go back and you
can watch and this is my very first
video and in my first video I thought I
had to be professional I thought I had
to be in a suit and sit down and have it
professionally filmed and memorize my
lines and be perfect and scripted and
this took two days to make and I had
three comments in that first year right
my mom my sister and this guy ABC TV ads
so in one year my first video going up I
only had three comments and two of them
were from my family it was really rough
and I made all the mistakes that we all
make and so the goal was something like
this and movement makers is to try to
help you guys shortcut the path so that
you don't have to take as long as I did
to get there and so emotional commitment
behind the content made a huge huge huge
huge huge difference you guys are
you're you know what you're talking
about you're experts right you've been
through something and that something can
help Inspire and serve a lot of people
the problem is and the problem for me
and in watching your videos the problem
for you is you're saying a lot of times
the right words and we're so focused on
saying the right words but there's no
emotion behind the words and if there's
no emotion behind the words then people
won't follow along they won't pay
attention they won't take notice they
won't do the action and your content
your channel won't grow so even more
important than the perfect words that
you're saying is how emotionally
connected are you to the thing that
you're saying it's the old Maya Angelou
quote the people remember how you made
them feel right that's what they
remember the most not what you said but
how you made them feel and if there's no
emotion behind the words you're saying
then they won't feel anything different
so
uh Steve had just incredible patience
with me for some reason he just loved me
for some reason I guess uh because it
took me a long time to get halfway
decent on camera on videos and um yeah I
must have been his little Pet Project or
charity case to help me get going so
emotional commitment is what we want to
start paying attention to in our content
all right deep breath let's start
looking at some old Evan Carmichael
videos and I will I will give myself
some coaching uh and look back so I
started in 2009
okay and and I don't we don't have to go
all the way back you guys can look at
that if you want this is 2011 now this
is my third year of making content okay
so it's not just like my first video
going up this is Evan in year three of
making content okay so first I'm making
all the classic mistakes right I have my
intro coming on as the first thing I
thought I had to be fancy and
professional and show off right so you
know we're not doing this no fancy
intros
thank you
hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Kevin in today's
video okay so already you know there's
no energy
hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of ask Evan right I'm
going to answer a question from one of
my readers Ina Oro who is asking about
the videos that I make how I make them
and why I make them so specifically
wrote in asking hi Evan you're just a
great guy for being consistent with your
messages thank you
I have two questions for you one in what
way do these messages you send to people
positively impact your business I mean
economically or financially and two do
you have people working on them and
sending them out for you or do you have
to write and work on people's questions
new ideas continuously when do you have
the core of your business to take care
of as well I want to say something like
this but I need to know if it's worth my
while thanks and Oro
so a couple of ideas here for you on on
how I create these videos
um most of the videos that I create come
from reader questions just like this
just like the one that that you wrote in
I don't make money from these videos
sometimes they're sponsored by a
corporate partner but most of the videos
are not sponsored I do
the videos because I really like helping
out entrepreneurs and this is what gets
me excited okay so thoughts what are
your thoughts on this video pop it pop
it in the chat love to see what's coming
up Chrissy says it's adorable Ida says
nice computer or is a computer oh
no this is 2011. that's an old school
computer uh is that Windows 95 I have no
idea uh how are you making money back
then so I I mean I wasn't at the
beginning right I had some some sponsors
on videos but like I said I just I love
doing it you know like I'm three years
in making content just because I love
doing it now I had I had sold my
business already a different business my
first company and I had some money so it
wasn't that I needed this to necessarily
pay off right away
um but I just love doing it right
they're like I'm how do you keep going
even on year three when you're
struggling and not getting traction and
not making any money well just because I
love actually doing it your smile is
underutilized no energy says Michael shy
Evan low energy compared to current
event it's it's somewhat flat that's
very kind Denise I'd say it's very flat
compare it to you now but still genuine
honest and real so this is this is the
difference right
uh Izumi says I don't feel Evan that I
feel now critiques monotone no energy no
powerful intro statement yeah so to
Denise's Point rather it's still genuine
honest and real this is where
this is where a lot of you are stuck and
I think honestly a lot of you are
already better than this
I'm still the same guy
and I still have the same a lot of same
information to share I mean I've
hopefully learned a little bit in the
past what 11 years but but
I'm still I know a lot at 2011 knows a
lot 2011 Evan 2011 Evan knows a lot and
you guys know a lot and you're already
better than me probably in this but this
is what a lot of people's videos look
like when they're getting into thought
leadership you like read somebody's
question and then you just start talking
and sharing and helping but because it's
flat and monotone people won't listen to
the actual content
and so I'm still the same guy this is
still me I have I have less hair but
more emotional commitment
foreign
that's the difference right so we don't
have to watch this whole thing we'll go
we'll go to the next one Zane says Evan
isn't bouncing bouncing helps okay so
2012. we're a full year later now and
now also just quick update these are not
the old thumbnails I used I don't even
have thumbnails back then we've just
been going back and updating all of our
old thumbnails so let's see how good
2012 Evan another year of practice four
years in now on my YouTube journey and
I'd love to see some comments down as
well as you start watching what do you
think
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome
to another edition of ask Evan today I'm
going to answer a question from one of
my Facebook viewers Jasmine who wrote in
a really really long message it's almost
a page here of a message I won't read
the whole thing but the Crux of it is uh
I know in my heart and mind that it
takes money to make money how do you
make money if you don't have the
finances to back it up and that's the
key thing I wanted to address today
yeah I want to get that notion out of
your head it doesn't take money to make
money it's not about how many resources
you have it's about how resourceful you
can be so if you look at all the the
famous successful entrepreneurs
especially in the past a lot of them
didn't come from wealthy backgrounds a
lot of them didn't have huge investors
they bootstrapped their way up you know
they they make the tough decisions and
did not go out and spend a lot of money
and the key here is not spending until
you're making money
okay so we don't have to watch the whole
thing quick thoughts better energy
better better lighting more comfortable
I'd say better you look more confident
more energy see more confident more
comfortable
uh still pitching in the beginning a
little more energy and you got right
into it yeah so I mean this is still I
think pretty bad if you if you're
comparing it to 2011 Evan then maybe
it's a little bit better but in terms of
emotional commitment
it still sucks there's still there's
still no real energy behind this I'm
just answering the question and again I
just didn't know this is just part of if
I knew and I had something to work on I
could make it better I thought here's
this person's question I'm going to
answer the question and and hopefully it
helps and move on to the next thing and
so there you know I might be a little
more practiced or comfortable in front
of the camera with an extra year under
my belt but in terms of the emotional
commitment behind the words it's not
really there and it's funny that you
know I'm watching back this is now 10
years ago that that whole line that I
used about it's about how resourceful
you are instead of how many resources
you have it's still something I'll say
today
it's like 20 20 2012 Evan was was a
pretty smart guy you know he had some
information there but but the delivery
still needed uh a lot of work and so
this you know again I think a lot of you
are already still ahead in your delivery
over 2012 Evan and you definitely have
the information inside your head and so
it's how do we bring
uh more energy out Zan saying how would
the emotionally committed Evan say today
well this is it like look at look at the
look at the range that I'm using now
look at the energy into look at me
laughing at myself now this is I mean if
you've seen in my videos on stage or how
we even start Movie Makers there's a lot
more energy just go watch any of my
videos where especially the espresso
ones where I'm talking it's it's just
being able to tap into that emotional
range instead of just being trapped in
your logical brain because the content
is the same it's the wrapping around it
I said something that Zen like there
he's going ooh the content is not that
different but the packaging and how I
wrapped it
has changed dramatically which allows it
to hit people in a stronger way
um Denise said so I thought this was
pretty good I need new definition for
emotional delivery and impact yeah and
we're so worried about saying the right
words
you're so worried about getting the
perfect script it's like the script is
not the thing the emotional commitment
you have behind the words that you're
saying is the thing that will move the
needle for people
and so every time we try to learn a new
skill the emotional commitment will
probably drop down a bit every time I
give you a new structure to say hey like
try to start with a powerful opinion now
you're so stressed out it wasn't
powerful thing did it get the powerful
opinion right it might did that work or
not right and so it's okay to take a
little bit of a step back every time
we're trying to learn something new but
I want this to be something that that
you're constantly looking at to improve
your content in watching yourself back
to say how how emotionally committed was
I to that message that was I feeling it
more than was I worried about saying the
right words
if you want to watch the full version of
this video as well as train live with me
twice a month to help you build your
movement and be around some other
amazing people just like you check out
my movement makers program the link to
join is right there next to me can't
wait to see you there continue to
believe and go join